Disney movies are so captivating that
taking our eyes off the action isn't an
easy thing to do but if you love Easter
eggs as much as we do you probably make
it a point to surf the background for
some clues we've got ten of the most
discreet positivity moments lined up for
you and if you're an incredible spin
you're gonna want to stick around until
the end for Gilley's and the scarred
carpet Disney Easter eggs can flash
across the screen without a moment's
notice
which is why keeping your eyes peeled
can help you spot them out Hercules is a
Disney classic that many of us can't get
enough of it's jam-packed with catchy
songs and lovable characters so what's
not to like in fact even Hades doesn't
seem to be that bad of a guy that is
unless you want him to hold Meg's
sentence and Hercules childhood against
him
Hades might be the movies big bad but he
isn't the only villain we get to see
flash across the screen as a matter of
fact The Lion King scar get some screen
time that's too juicy to ignore after
shedding his clumsy ways Hercules
becomes his villages hero which turns
him into a pretty big deal but soon
enough Hercules realizes that theme
isn't what it's cracked out to be so he
confides in Phil while wearing a lion
skin on his shoulders
once you paused this scene you clearly
see scars felt being paraded around by
the hero Hercules thro scar at Phil's
feet and in a way this scene brings a
strange sense of justice to mufasa's
murder Toy Story and the Binford toolbox
if there's one animated film that took
the world by storm its Toy Story this
movie is filled with Easter eggs that
many of us already know of but there's
one that's managed to slip through the
cracks despite becoming best buds by the
end of the film Woody and Buzz bump
heads when they first meet their feud
starts when Woody begins to feel
threatened by Andy's newest toy and
chooses to act out of jealousy before
long Woody's actions cause them to get
kidnapped by Sid who's basically the
worst toy owner in the universe to
secure his latest catch Sid traps woody
under a milk crate and places a heavy
toolbox on top of it during the scene we
come face to face with a hilarious
Easter egg that many of us wouldn't
think twice about however if you've ever
watched the 90s sitcom home improvement
this scene probably stuck out to you
like a sore thumb
many of you know Tim Allen is the actor
behind Buzz Lightyear's voice and he
also played the leading man in home
improvement so it's no big surprise that
Disney chose to label SIDS to a box with
the Binford brand which is a popular
tool manufacturer used by Tim's
character in the show it's hard to catch
the Binford logo if you don't pause the
film at the perfect moment would love to
see you try the Beauty and the Beast
signpost Disney animators love to throw
in a handful of inside jokes when
working on a film so we're not surprised
that Beauty and the Beast has some
hidden gems in it that few people can
spot out during one of the first scenes
of the movie Belle's father Maurice
announces that he'll be going on a trip
but despite following a familiar route
he gets lost along the way Maurice and
his horse come across a signpost with
faded writing on it and after a quick
glance they choose to follow the darker
path since the Beauty and the Beast is
supposed to take place in France many of
us didn't think twice about the cities
displayed on the signpost however once
this scene is paused we see that Disney
animators took this opportunity to lay
an Easter egg although the writing is
hard to read the words Anaheim and
Valencia can easily be spotted on the
sign and funny enough these are where
the famous disneyland resorts can be
found on a side note many Disney
animators receive their arts and
entertainment degree at Valencia College
which is why the word Valencia is often
strategically placed throughout the
Disney franchise a bug's life and the
Traveling Circus at first glance you
wouldn't think that Dumbo and a bug's
life had anything in common but this
couldn't be further from the truth
in fact there's a major Dumbo reference
in a bug's life that most people have
trouble spotting out without pausing the
film
Dumbo might have come out five decades
before it bug's life did but that didn't
stop creators from drawing inspiration
from the old classic in a bug's life
were introduced to Petey fleas and his
gang of traveling circus bugs problem is
the ringmaster has little to no
credibility which is why he tends to
cheat his customers out of money but
despite being a villain at first Petey
chooses to do the right thing and helps
the ants defeat hopper once the evil
grasshopper is no longer a threat Petey
and his circus bugs pack up their
belongings and hit the road the bugs
board their train and take off with
lighter hearts but not before flashing
their trains logo for all to see Petey
traveling train has the words Casey jr.
cookies which is a direct reference to
the train that's used to transport Dumbo
and his friends so despite the many
decades that separate these films
they're tied together by this low-key
yet effective reference finding Dory and
Riley some Disney movies have more
Easter eggs than others and finding Dory
is one of them fans have spotted a
handful of these while watching the
hilarious film but some are harder to
catch than others
during the aquarium scene we see Dory
swimming up to a window of children and
although this scene doesn't seem to be
out of the ordinary there's an
inside-out character hiding in the
background
can you guys spot her out in the crowd a
wide-eyed Riley is looking into the
aquarium as Dory swims up to the glass
this cameo is hard to catch since the
inside-out character only appears for a
split second as many of you know Riley
and her family moved to San Francisco
which is where Dory was taken during the
film so funny enough these two
characters came inches away from each
other without ever knowing it another
Easter Egg that's worth mentioning is
the one that appears in the background
during the scene where Hank is holding
Dory in a plastic cup if you pause this
shot you'll see a wall-e calendar nailed
on to the lower right corner of the
screen stick around to find out which
other finding Dory Easter eggs defies
the laws of logic inside out and the
birds on the wire inside out is a
brilliant movie that gives us a bird's
eye view on what's happening inside of
the body when a young girl named Riley
moves away from her hometown she has a
hard time getting accustomed to her new
life as Riley enters her teenage years
her emotions start to get out of whack
causing joy to leave the building inside
out is an oscar-winning movie that
teaches children about their emotions
much like the Disney classics that came
before it inside out is no stranger when
it comes to Easter eggs however some of
them are so subtle that they might as
well not exist do any of you remember
the short animation for the birds that
Disney released in the year of 2000 well
if you do you might be one of the few
people who were able to spot out this
cameo Disney animators didn't waste any
time placing Easter eggs in inside outs
basket which is why these birds are
showcased right off the bat
while Riley and her parents are driving
to San Francisco the flock of birds from
the short animation
be spotted hanging out on a telephone
wire if this is your first time noticing
them make sure to leave a bird emoji in
the comments below
monsters Inc and the woody stickers
monsters Inc is a disney film that has
no shortage of Toy Story references in
fact there's so many of them present
that it's hard not to notice them so
knowing this we're going to show you an
easter egg that few fans stumble upon
due to how quickly it flashes across the
screen in monsters ink we see thousands
of doors being prepped for
transportation problem is they don't
stick around for very long which is what
makes spotting this reference so
challenging but chances are if you pause
the movie whenever a door is flying by
you'll see that they're decorated with a
variety of stickers and believe it or
not that these stickers belong to the
Toy Story franchise in fact they're from
the TV show Woody's roundup which is
where everyone's favorite cowboy
originates from the Monsters Inc
franchise goes hand in hand with the Toy
Story movies since they both deal with
young children and since Mike and Sulley
are constantly barging in to the kids
rooms it's only normal for tons of toys
to line the floor the good dinosaur meet
same pink is an adorable Disney
character who never hesitates to help
out a friend
and much like Randall Boggs from
monsters Inc he has the ability to
camouflage himself in fact ink is said
to appear in every single Disney movie
ever created and while this sounds a
little extreme it reminds us to always
keep an eye out for her paint the seven
armed octopus the good dinosaur is no
exception to this rule which is why you
can expect to see Hank lurking in the
background at some point or another but
spotting him out won't be easy so get
ready to press that pause button at a
moment's notice
remember when Arlo gets spooked and
falls into the water while Hank makes a
quick cameo during this frightful scene
his big eyes can be spotted at the
bottom left corner of the screen
but recognizing him won't be easy since
he's perfectly camouflaged into the
rocks
for this reason it's pretty much
impossible to spot Hank out without some
help but if you guys are interested in
seeing every single one of Hanks cameos
let us know in the comments section
below
finding Dory or finding Darla's as
promised we're circling back to unravel
one of the most puzzling finding Dory
Easter eggs of
time but it just might scare the bejesus
out of you it's no secret that Darla is
one of the most terrifying characters in
the Finding Nemo franchise in fact one
looked at her curled lips embrace
infested smile can give you nightmares
for life but the real reason that Darla
is such a hated character has everything
to do with her strange desire to harm
fish and animals alight do you remember
the scene where Hank and Dory meet for
the first time if so you probably recall
how hank was flawlessly camouflaged into
a cat poster well take a look on the
right hand side of the poster but try
not to scream hung on the wall is the
classic Darla picture that we've all
come to fear so what's her picture doing
in the basement of an aquarium well our
best guess is that Darla's mom or dad
works with sick ocean life which could
explain her strange fascination with
fish The Incredibles know Kate's allowed
if there's one thing that Edna mode has
always stressed it's at her superheroes
are not allowed to wear capes at first
many of us couldn't help but find this
rule a little strange especially since
most heroes enjoy having capes attached
to their costumes
Edna goes through the trouble of naming
some of the heroes who passed away due
to getting betrayed by their billowing
capes but we never once thought that mr.
and mrs. incredible we're best friends
with these people however during a
flashback of the couple's wedding day we
clearly see a crowd of superheroes
clapping in the background and three of
them are the keep wearing heroes who
Edna later mentions this is a sad Easter
egg if we've ever seen one but at least
we know the real reason why Edna has a
deep hatred for capes before you go make
sure to let us know which paused moment
surprised you the most in the comments
below and that's the end of our video
don't forget to subscribe to the themes
for more great content to come your way
thanks for watching and see you next
time
[Music]